data it's the great differentiator in
today's competitive landscape every day
your business pulls in huge quantities
of it from web interactions to inventory
counts diagnostic reports to consumer
feedback and then it's it's separated
across systems unstructured and
disjointed being able to look out across
all that data connect the dots and see
the bigger picture is key to your
company's success and survival machine
learning gives you this ability the
chance to view your data in a whole new
way instead of following code and
commands it learns from what you compile
to find patterns and insights that not
only make you smarter but can
revolutionize how your business runs at
Google we use machine learning to
optimize all our products in real-time
traffic and maps spam detection and
Gmail and facial recognition and photos
and now we've designed a platform
especially for you to predict when to
ramp up production know when your
customers are ready to upgrade diagnose
new diseases with speed and accuracy the
more data you bring to it the more
unique insights you're given the more
opportunities you have to redefine how
your enterprise runs this is the future
of how machines and people work together
to transform how we all do business the
technology is here and it's waiting for
you will it make the difference for your
enterprise
you